whatsapp is now adding crypto payments
it's a very very big deal and i think a
lot of people are going to misunderstand
what's happening here as we know
facebook or what is now called meta has
already launched something called the
novi digital wallet it's a normal
digital wallet that is going to support
all types of cryptocurrencies whether
it's their own thing called dieum or
it's stable coins bitcoin or anything
else novi digital wallet has already
been released they have been pioneering
or piloting a new type of corridor
between the united states and guatemala
people can go they can download the novi
digital wallet between the us and
guatemala they can go ahead and do
remittance payments using the paxos
digital dollar or stablecoin now what is
really interesting about this specific
pilot that they've been running now for
a couple of weeks is that there was a
lot of friction involved in it you had
to actually go download a brand new app
you had to be onboarded you had to go
ahead you had to acquire the paxos
digital dollar and then you had to send
it so quite literally you're asking
people to change their consumer behavior
but now all of a sudden meta is going
ahead and integrating
the novi digital wallet into whatsapp so
users in the us there's a small select
group of people who will be able to go
ahead and do this and what's so
fascinating about this to me is that you
now are going to be able to send money
as seamlessly effortlessly efficiently
and instantly and as cheaply as you can
information hear that again
what the internet did to information
they made it seamless efficient
effortless instant and free to send
information we are now doing to money
because in a digital world information
and money are the same exact thing money
is information in the digital world and
so with whatsapp if you can text you now
can transact you're gonna simply be able
to go into whatsapp you're gonna be able
to hit the little paperclip to add an
attachment there'll be a payment option
you click payment and then bam you're
ready to rock and roll the beautiful
thing about this is that whatsapp has
two plus billion users around the world
we are talking about one of the largest
messaging apps in the entire earth going
ahead and now saying we are going to add
an integration that will allow people to
interact with and transact to buy sell
and hold cryptocurrencies they're
starting with a stable coin that packs
those digital dollars eventually over
time i believe that they will add
support for all of these including
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies and
so if we can get more adoption of
digital wallets via whatsapp going ahead
and onboarding their two plus billion
users this ultimate is a net positive
and it pushes the entire space forward i
think that people will look at this and
say oh what is whatsapp doing here but i
think this is a much much bigger deal
than most people realize and so if we go
ahead and we look at their user growth
over time you can see that they don't
just have the two billion users but it
has been growing very very quickly they
forexed that user base in about seven
years or so and so once you start to
think about this the beauty to me is not
only that they are going to integrate it
but it's the ability for people to start
to understand money and information can
be sent as fast and as cheaply as each
other and on top of that you don't need
to change your consumer behavior as long
as you're in the app you now can stay
there and send money that's a very very
big deal in my opinion joe what do you
think about whatsapp doing this
i mean i think it's pretty big like two
billion people that means one out of
four people roughly uh in the world have
whatsapp so from an interconnected kind
of standpoint of access this is massive
i think it depends on kind of what your
what your belief is in uh novi and and
whatsapp controlling this and meta and
so forth uh from a centralization
standpoint but i think it's big for uh
kind of these payment systems in general
right just anywhere that people can get
more access to this kind of stuff on a
large scale like whatsapp i think is
important and maybe this is just a pilot
program or a test but ultimately if it
goes well you have to assume that
they'll end up rolling this out to kind
of everyone so whether it's payments
across borders or just transacting with
people in your local area i think
anything that people can do to
accelerate that infrastructure digitally
is probably a good thing and the more
people that become accustomed and uh and
are associated with crypto and digital
payments in general i think is a good
thing for the space in general but i
think uh ultimately like people are just
going to drive back to the solution of
bitcoin
john what do you think whatsapp is
massive right you can't underestimate
that um foreign countries i think use it
a lot more than domestically and i
believe that in india and brazil they
already have the ability to kind of do
this with fiat currencies and not using
crypto or stable coins so it'll be
interesting to see i'm curious why they
chose paxos i know they're using
coinbase as kind of like a custodian for
all of this stuff um so that's a good
move for them one of the most highly
respected exchanges i think in the world
uh especially in the united states but
this final program is rolled out in the
united states we're gonna see over time
what kind of users actually use this
product but they've already onboarded
two billion people right onto whatsapp
so we'll see over we'll see over time
who actually uses this product
the other piece of this uh that i think
is um is really interesting is that once
you start to actually use this you could
quickly see that whatsapp is not only
for uh peer-to-peer type payments like
me to pay you or you to pay me all of a
sudden if now i can go to the store and
i can pay for things right if i can
start to actually what if uh they add
you know dollars then they add uh
something like bitcoin then all of a
sudden they start to add uh stocks or
they start to add other types of assets
like could they actually transform
whatsapp into like a true super app that
has built the messaging capabilities
with two plus billion users and then
start to add financial services into it
i don't know but like that's the type of
stuff that i think if you look out 10
years or so it gets really really
powerful really fast you don't have to
leave the app to be to do this
no that's the whole point that is that
is a key part yeah that's what i'm
saying you don't change their user
behavior you basically just hit that
little paper clip that's like to add an
attachment and normally when you hit
that you could add a photo you could add
a video you could add whatever to the
message right to the stream now when you
hit it there's a payment option if
you're in this pilot and when you just
hit payment it says how much do you want
to send type it in bam send it and it
sends them the money across whatsapp
they're gonna have they're gonna
absolutely i also do yeah whatsapp's
about to go wild they're about to crush
it i also think that yeah people in the
united states underestimate this like
anywhere you travel around the world
especially in in uh in poorer countries
or people of less economic standing they
they all use whatsapp whatsapp is
massive especially outside of the united
states so maybe people aren't as
familiar with the people that are
watching in the united states because
they don't use it on a day-to-day basis
but people in other countries this is
literally what they use all day long
right so from a payments infrastructure
standpoint i think it's a massive thing
for uh whatsapp to do it just comes down
to like how quickly they're rolled out
what additional features do they add and
like how quickly does it scale to other
people
yeah the the uh piece to me that becomes
really interesting is if they could
into if they could get enough users
using it and they could get enough
velocity of the money right and then
they started to integrate other types of
financial services outside of just
payments then you start to say to
yourself okay uh that's all great from a
user experience standpoint the downside
important to call off the downside they
got a lot of information about you
right and so how is that being used now
one thing i did see in i think was the
verge had a great article on uh this
announcement today is that the payments
don't interrupt or
cause any issues with the end-to-end
encryption that whatsapp has and so you
still have that level of privacy but
what about the other information are you
now all of a sudden gonna have ads
inside of whatsapp that you get an ad
fed to you based on your payment history
plus your facebook data like and your
instagram browsing has i mean like you
start getting this like weird world
where it's like okay like where's the
line we don't know yet right and i i'll
tend to give them uh the benefit of the
doubt to start because historically
whatsapp has actually been left alone
for the most part now the founders did
leave whatsapp right and one of them now
works on signal uh but i do think that
uh this is a net positive and ultimately
goes back to uh i really wrote i should
pull up the receipt that uh the most
important announcement that facebook
made through all the dm libra like all
that stuff i kept saying it was it's the
wallet
the wallet is the most important thing
if they hand billions of people a
digital wallet it is game on globally
here they are
fast forward a couple of months now
they're giving people these digital
wallets it's gonna be game on globally